greta thunberg issued another
proclamation condemning all of us for
our selfishness and she does this
periodically periodically i mean like
three times a week
so if this is a long one it went on for
like five minutes
um but we'll play a little bit of it and
and this portion i thought was funny
primarily just because she talks about
the thoughts and feelings of fish
and how we have to respect their
thoughts and feelings so let's listen
and finally the animals every year
we kill more than 60 billion animals
excluding fish whose numbers are so
great
that we only measure their lives by
weight
what about their thoughts and feelings
some animals plan for the future forge
friendships
that last for decades they play
they help each other they show signs
of what we call empathy but 70
of the animals we farm live inside
factories
in the united states that number is 99
their lives are short and terrible
how will we be judged
it is heartbreaking to know all this but
it is also our opportunity
we know what we can do we can change the
way we farm
we can change what we eat we can change
how we treat nature some of us
have lots of choices while some have
none at all
those with the most power have the most
responsibility
and most of us can do something
so what will you do
um nothing i remember i'm not gonna do
anything i'm just i'm being totally
honest with you
greta i'm not gonna do anything at all
about these problems that you have
outlined
um and i'm not even denying that some of
them
you know uh in a perfect world
would i if i were setting up my perfect
world would it include
factory farming no
what am i going to do about it nothing
really
and part of that is you know you people
have taken this on as your cause
but it's and there's there are a lot of
you know a lot of complaints a lot of
criticisms
but really short on solutions
so just saying we can change let's
change the way we eat
let's change this and that in what way
exactly
and you got to be real specific
because we you know we got a lot of
people to feed in this country
300 plus mills 330 million people
and counting especially because as we
discussed earlier
the borders being poorest people people
more and more people pouring in here
every day and that's
more and more people to feed a lot a lot
of mouths to feed
so what's your plan for making sure that
all those people get fed cicadas
you think we're all going to live on
worms i mean what is your plan exactly
and uh also just so you know
uh fish don't don't really have thoughts
or feelings at all
um they're they're basically like
biological
machines so you don't you don't have to
worry too much about how the fish are
feeling because
they're not really feeling anything they
don't they don't have the neurological
equipment for that
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated